imagine we listed all integers in a
growing spiral and colored the prime
numbers blue and left the composite
numbers black one interesting question
we may ask is how many Prime's are there
compared to composites first let's zoom
out to see the big picture notice the
prime color is dense in the center and
slowly drops off in the distance but
never seems to end one way I like to
think about this is as follows imagine
there is a tree at the center which is
infinitely high the leaves which drop
from this tree represent prime numbers
which are scattered unpredictably below
dense near the base of the tree and as
we walk away from this tree we find
fewer leaves though we always find them
this is exactly what happens when we
look at larger and larger integers we
always find more Prime's though the
number of primes we find gradually drops
the further we looked so let's return to
our question how many Prime's are there
less than some integer X if we make a
table we see the number of primes is
always increasing though as we search
further we find fewer and fewer let's
graph the number of primes found on the
vertical axis and the search size X on
the horizontal as we zoom out to include
billions of numbers notice the curve
never flatlines it's always rising
albeit gradually
first let's think about the density of
primes less than some integer X we can
find the density by dividing the number
of primes found by the search size for
the first 100 integers we find 25 primes
therefore 25% are prime of the first
1,000 integers we find twelve hundred
and twenty nine primes twelve point two
nine percent are prime of the first one
million integers seven point eight four
percent are prime and the first 100
million integers contained five point
seven six percent prime as we search
further this density continues to drop
though the speed at which it drops slows
down here is a graph of the search size
on the horizontal axis and the prime
density on the vertical notice that as
we zoom out the primes are a vanishing
proportion of all integers
amazingly we find this formula in nature
we see it in galaxies storms
flowers and even inside our bodies as
the design of least resistance known as
the logarithmic spiral notice that as
the spiral rotates it gets further and
further away from the center incredibly
the rotation rate of a logarithmic
spiral is related to the density of
primes as follows we have the number of
rotations call this Phi and the distance
from the center call this R if we graph
Phi against R and zoom out we see they
are related according to the natural
logarithm this means the natural
logarithm of the distance is related to
the number of rotations the graph of the
natural logarithm is commonly written
using the variable names Y and X as y
equals the natural logarithm of X notice
the graph tapers off in the same way the
density of primes gradually decreases
hmm the final step is to invert this by
changing the y axis to 1 divided by the
natural logarithm of X and when we zoom
out we find the exact same curve
generated when we plot the density of
primes let's confirm this by overlapping
the two plots in green is a graph of the
line y equals 1 over the natural
logarithm of X and in red is the plot of
prime number density up to X as we zoom
out they approach each other the further
we zoom out the more accurate the green
estimate becomes this is known as the
asymptotic law of distribution of prime
numbers we now have a formula to
accurately tell us the density of primes
without counting
the density of primes up to some integer
X is approximately 1 divided by the
natural logarithm of X or lon X so let's
say you need to know the density of
primes between 1 and 100 trillion simple
1 divided by lawn of 100 trillion equals
3 point 1 percent
compare this to the actual result from
counting all primes which is 3 point 2
percent this is off by 0.1 percent and
as we check larger and larger numbers
the difference approaches zero realize
now that we can use this formula for
prime density to estimate the number of
primes up to X the number of primes is
the area under the density curve for
which we can simplify by assuming
density is constant so number of primes
equals size times density or X divided
by lawn X this is the prime number
theorem
here is a graph of y equals x divided by
lon X in blue and in yellow is a plot of
an actual count of primes notice as we
zoom out these lines eventually overlap
as we look to infinity
and that is it we have a formula which
tells us approximately how many Prime's
there are up to any value no counting
needed for example let's say we need to
know the number of primes less than 100
trillion 100 trillion divided by the
natural log of 100 trillion equals 3
point 1 trillion
compare this to the actual count which
is 3 point two trillion this is over
99.99% accurate even at this relatively
small scale so to recap given a search
size up to some integer X the prime
density is about 1 divided by lawn X and
the number of primes is about X divided
by lawn X this is the prime number
theorem